Good morning, John. Thank you for your pea video.
My main problem with it is that it's very difficult to live up to. What a beautiful thing you did.
Folks over on the nerdfighteria subreddit have been having a good ol' time.
There's this
and then this one happened
and then this
and this for some reason
but then also this?
Oh, yeah!
One of my favorite things about being alive in the world right now is that I can Google pretty much anything and it's there. Like,
I'm not gonna look any of these things up before I say them and I'm gonna put the pictures that I find after I film the video.
Show me a cat on a horse
an owl with a hat
A balloon--
Ninja, I don't know what that is.
Show me a dog on a bunny. That doesn't sound like it's possible,
but I bet somebody figured out how to do it.
Was it good? Probably good.
Probably not better than owl with a hat maybe better than...
Christmas ferret. Just throwing the first result on here, no matter what it is. Christmas ferret!
John, I recently changed my house over to use Google Wi-Fi because it's a really---they're really quite well-done things,
but you could either get one, or you get three for the price of two. And so I-
I only needed two so I've ended up with this extra Google home router thing.
And honestly, I'm a little bit mad about it. *oh no angry hank*
Like, my instinct is to hold on to this thing, like, in case my house gets bigger, I guess?
It's like $100 plus thing and it's just gonna sit in a closet somewhere
until it becomes obsolete enough that I feel okay taking it to Staples to get recycled.
This is bad, it makes me upset, and there's only one thing to do with it.
*intense head banging music*
Gotta sell it on Craigslist
cuz somebody
wants it
And if I hit it with a hammer
It would become garbage
See the situation is that Google mostly destroyed the economic value in the router by not offering me a discounted 2-pack.
But people worked hard to create that thing. There's still value inside of it, and I should honor those people's hard work,
Yeah?
Even though I really do want to see what's on the inside of it and there weren't any pictures of it on the internet.
That's frustrating for me. And look,
it's probably also frustrating for a lot of people watching this, because I kinda made a pact with you.
I went and bought a hammer for 5 dollars and did the whole thing
With the dramatic lighting and then there's like the title of the video *upside down hank* like I feel bad
*an absolutely remarkable thing available for preorder now coming out september 25*
That's better! This is the router that my Google home system is replacing and it's a P. O. S.
What is this form factor? Why make it like this so that it's impossible for it to stay up!
It is always falling out--- just the cords on the back of it yank it over. Yes. I filmed this before I smashed it
So I don't even know how satisfying it was to destroy that thing yet, but I'm gonna find out. Look it's from 2012
It's done with. They're going for like 20 bucks on Amazon right now and at a certain point
It just isn't worth it for me to stick something on Craigslist,
Have somebody weird come to my house and get a router. Meet me in the Target parking lot.
Who can compete with the convenience of Amazon?
dftba.com, your friendly neighborhood e-tailer serving now
McElroy merch and also The Baby-Sitters' Club Club: the best in all of the baby-sitters club podcasts. Speaking of dftba.com
Let's throw up that weird pea shirt
Alright, John. See you on Tuesday
Am I gonna eat the whole donut? No, I'm not. I'm a 38 year old man.
I'm not gonna eat a rusty hammer donut, okay? Bye.